Last question.
Okay.
Thanks.
Also for continuing the electric series.
I haven't listened to all of the lectures,
but it seems like you focus very much on the appeal of the biblical stories to
the individual psychology.
Do you have any thoughts on the relative importance of crowd psychology to the
uh,
appeal instinct?
However,
the Bible and also the,
the reason why the Bible or the biblical stories took precedence over other,
um,
ideologies which could have taken its place.
Okay.
Well,
let's go to the second one first.
I think it's the same thing that happens when someone,
okay.
Both creates an edits,
a great movie.
Okay.
It's no one knows,
like,
imagine how many choices are they're in a great movie.
Let's say it's an animated movie because absolutely everything in an animated
movie is constructed.
Everything.
There's,
God only knows how many choices.
Like maybe there's millions of choices,
you know,
and each choice is guided by some intuition of narrative suitability or beauty
or there's some higher ideal motivating it,
right?
The desire to produce a masterpiece.
Maybe that's it.
That was certainly the case with the Disney movies,
for example.
And so that that aspiration then then makes the decisions.
And so I would say,
well something like that guided the writing and the selection of the stories in,
in the biblical Canon now
could have there been other stories included while the Catholics and the
Protestants don't have the same biblical tradition and neither do the Jews and
the Christians.
And so it isn't exactly clear what to make of that,
you know,
I mean that's a can in some sense to the discussion we just had about Islam and
Christianity.
Um,
in some sense I've left that aside,
that specific question except in so far as I've just answered because I'm trying
to take what we have,
which I know is that the root of our culture and to figure out what it is that
we have,
why it is that we have it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I've made some attempt to explain that in the manner that I just described,
but I don't have a final answer.
Like could it have been different?
It could have been different at some levels,
but the same at others.
You know,
I mean,
one of the things that's the scholars of comparative religion who haven't been
infected fatally with postmodernism have definitely realized so young,
for example,
in Elliott and people who are interested in grand narratives,
one of the things they pointed out quite clearly is that there's,
there's,
there's a set of common mythological themes across many,
and I tried to outline that in maps of meaning.
And that worked out quite nicely for me at least as far as I was concerned
because once I had the basic archetipal structure mapped out,
it opened up all sorts of stories to me from all sorts of different cultures.
And that's been unbelievably useful.
Like the Mesopotamian story of it,
the Enuma Elish when,
when I figured out what that meant as far as I was concerned,
like I've never forgotten that.
It just seared itself into my memory.
And the same with the Egyptian stories and you know,
some Buddhist writing said,
I've read it in some,
the Tao Te Ching is also very powerful.
So I think that things can be different on one level and that same metta
another,
but that humanity kind of coalesces on what's the same over a reasonable period
of time because there isn't that many ways that human beings can live properly
as individuals and as groups together.
And so there's this constant force that makes our ethical presuppositions
converge and then that's automatically expressed in the stories.
It's something like that now.
It's an imperfect process and it's full of error.
So.
Yup.
[inaudible]
so
one announcement,
uh,
well two announcements.
The next lecture I believe is November 14th,
so I'll hopefully finish off the story of Jacob,
looks like it.
And then I'm also appearing on a panel with Gad Saad and or an amateur Jay on
November 11th and there's still quite a few tickets available for that.
So if you're interested,
you could go to my website and pick up those tickets.
It should be,
well,
hopefully it'll be interesting.
I think it will be and it might be too interesting.
That's one possibility.
So we'll see.
But I'm going to do two more of these this year,
and I hope I get through the story of Joseph and then I can start in the new
year with the exodus.
And that's a story that I know quite well.
And the exodus and Leviticus.
And what's the one after that?
You,
yes.
Thank you.
Um,
so I'm very much looking forward to that because that is one killer story
mountain,
so,
and I've got some surprises for that as well.
So anyway,
so thank you very much for coming.
And,
uh,
hopefully we'll see you November for
14.